et oui il peut apporter les solutions
grâce aux satellites
évidemment qui nous permettent
d'observer la terre et d'agir pour
trouver justement des solutions à ce
réchauffement climatique. Nous avons
notamment les programmes Copernicus qui
sont des satellites qui nous permettent
d'observer les océans, l'augmentation de
la température des niveaux de l'eau, qui permettent
également de suivre l'activité humaine
et le dégagement de pollution à travers le
monde et donc nous pouvons à partir de
ces données réagir pour inverser la courbe.
Nous votons jeudi une
résolution sur le green deal donc la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
par l'Union Européenne. Je propose
un amendement qui va demander
l'utilisation du spatial pour observer
la terre et trouver ces
fameuses solutions en ayant observé les
différents cataclysmes. Donc pour moi il
est clair que il ne peut pas y avoir un
green deal sérieux s'il n'y a pas un
investissement sérieux dans le domaine spatial.
C'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui puisque
l'Australie a appelé au secours l'Union
européenne et six satellites copernicus
qui fournissent en temps réel des images
de tous les incendies qui sont en
Australie. Ce qui permet d'évacuer les
populations. Ce qui permet d'aiguiller
les pompiers dans leur lutte contre
contre le sinistre. C'était déjà le cas
en Amazonie. C'était aussi le cas dans le
cadre de tempête qui peut y avoir en
Amérique du nord.
On peut dire encore une fois que
l'Europe est leader dans ce domaine là
et il faut insister pour que
Copernicus puisse encore avoir davantage
de moyens pour lutter partout dans le
monde contre ces sinistres.